[Música]
y
hola qué tal es un gran placer estar con
ustedes este viernes 19 de abril viernes
santo de hecho les deseamos una feliz
semana santa a todos y todos los que nos
están escuchando en este momento en
cualquier lugar del mundo
me acompañan hoy aquí en estudio paloma
martínez leonardo gimeno y leonora
chapman bienvenidos y bienvenidas y como
se habrán podido dar cuenta también
tenemos un invitado hoy aquí en el
estudio 26 de radio canalda y se trata
de andrés ramos colombiano que está acá
en montreal haciendo una pasantía y
bueno él trabaja en colombia con el
grupo comunicarte y bueno vamos a
charlar bienvenido andrés muchísimas
gracias y vamos a hablar contigo un
poquitito más tarde sobre la razón
tu presencia aquí hoy y aquí en canadá
en montreal lo que estás haciendo y
bueno entonces vamos a comenzar como de
costumbre para no salirnos de los
esquemas entonces
cuando uno se sale del esquema opina
fuera del texto
[Risas]
que está opinando fuera del ex fuera del
recipiente entonces a mí me gusta
[Música]
depende del contexto bueno entonces
leonora a ti te interesó había hablando
de los hechos así que nos han que nos
han llamado la atención a ti te interesó
esta historia de un barco que va a pasar
encallado
en los hielos árticos para hacer una
investigación dicen que es la
investigación más grande de todos los
tiempos sobre el derretimiento del hielo
en el ártico me hace acordar un poco la
historia ocurrida hace un más o menos
más de un siglo y medio cuando esta
expedición franklin del franklin vino de
inglaterra busca hacia él buscando el
pasaje paso por el noroeste en el ártico
y que terminó atrapado por los hielos y
no pudieron salir más murieron dos años
vieron a todos por muchas causas esto es
un poco lo mismo es un barco esta vez
científico alemán que va a venir al
ártico a hacer esta investigación y que
se va a dejar atrapar va y va a llegar
al ártico y se va a dejar en algún lugar
no va a dejar seguir a la deriva que los
hielos lo lleven a donde sean el ártico
y en un momento dado los hielos se van a
cerrar sobre el barco iba a quedar
encallado y estamos hablando aquí de el
próximo invierno del invierno 2019
hablando de septiembre de 2019 se inicia
la explicación van a participar un total
de 600 personas de 17 países entre ellos
canadá van a ser abastecidos a
diferencia del franklin van a ser
abastecidos con aviones y eb en fin
mejor helicópteros
y después de esto pues esos datos van a
ser utilizados por miles de científicos
y un poco lo que se tiene esta idea es
que el barco sea como una base para una
red de puestos de observación científico
que trataran de comprender mejor dice la
dinámica del hielo en tiempo real y
estos científicos se hicieron la gran
pregunta porque están observando que el
hielo en el ártico se está derritiendo
en una proporción del 12% cada década
desde 1979 que están midiendo estos
datos y la gran pregunta que se hacen es
cuánto tiempo tenemos antes de que se
haya ido completamente
bueno a lo mejor no le va a suceder lo
que le sucedió exactamente porque cada
vez hay menos hielo además lo de
franklin se comieron entre ellos tenía
nada más eso es una historia de
canibalismo popular pero claro pero acá
es diferente porque ellos van a tener
aprovisionamiento con helicópteros por
vía terrestre y los científicos se van a
ir un poco y cambiando van a llegar
nuevos se van viejos porque hay
diferentes investigaciones que se van a
llevar a cabo y dicen que es la más
grande de todos los tiempos entonces me
parece que es muy importante que puedan
determinar cuándo no va a haber más y
hielo congelado en el verano en el
ártico esa es una de las más grandes
investigaciones que se hicieron en el en
la antártida fue una misión canadiense y
en canadá vea en el norte camina hacia
traemos alemanes
esta investigación está organizada por
uno dos o tres grandes institutos
alemanes
un rompehielos que es alemán me empiezan
a partir de noruega pero se van son 17
países la parte artística
avn entonces son ellos los que iniciaron
la investigación interesante seguir que
es fundamental con lo que está
sucediendo ahora es fundamental saber
cuánto tiempo queda para que los
entendemos porque dicen que cuando se
termine de descongelar todos las costas
van a desaparecer están contentos no
porque esta posibilidad de que el ártico
no se congele abre una nueva vía
marítima
desde exacto de este a oeste y pasando
ya no tendrán que pasar por el canal de
panamá tamo solía ser antes por el
estrecho de magallanes ahora van a pasar
directamente por arriba
por más meses que antes y cuando
comiencen a hacerlo
además la importante de esto es no sólo
eso sino también las implicaciones que
va a haber una vez que él como decía
también leonardo cuando ya no haya más
hielo en el verano o en los veranos que
implica eso que el suelo está perdiendo
gas el perfil del sol
hace años que está guardado ahí vamos a
ver lo que contiene que hay un montón de
científicos que hablan de que eso
tóxicos va a ser tóxico pero de una
manera increíble para el ser humano para
el ecosistema nos pasa a través del agua
y al agua de riego y el agua que se bebe
entonces si hay muchos temas conexos
esta investigación vamos a seguir de
cerca eso leonardo diga bueno qué pasó
con este famoso 155 millones d
de downloads e ilegales es la primera
del primer camino 55 millones de nuevo
congestión supongo que en algún lado se
haber confeccionado yo por ejemplo no no
no lo baje digo no lo viví la congestión
yo
porque tú tenías que ya compre bien no
no no tengo que te veo el canal
directamente no debes de bajarlo pero
hay gente que lo baja es más hay una
cuestión a día dentro de la serie con
los elefantes hay alguien que quiere
elefantes no voy a decir spoiler
y resulta que en este primer episodio
los elefantes no llegan y si no no hay
elefantes ya había un post en internet
que decía si cada uno de los que bajó
ilegalmente una copia cuando las
[Risas]
ganancias de los productores de esta
serie no hay 50 millones de piratas es
mucho dinero en la octava temporada hay
muchísima plata
entonces no nos vamos a lamentar en el
segundo capítulo ahora el domingo que
viene a las nueve de la noche hora
canadiense
yo tengo una cena y me disfrazo a la
temática de uno de los no puedo no puedo
decirlo
o sea que lo pensé y entrar de rodillas
con los grandes
así que no voy a disfrazar otra parte de
la consigna era disfrazado de uno de los
personajes vivos o muertos porque una de
las características del game of thrones
es que se va muriendo la gente
personaje importante los muertos
resucitan si también yo tengo toda la
serie con amigos de las siete temporadas
temporadas un amigo muy querido la
derecha
[Risas]
bueno encadenamos acción paloma algo muy
curioso para hombría y es que un
indígena canadiense fue detenido por la
policía porque lo confundieron con un
mexicano y pensaban que era
narcotraficante como dije él hizo sus
propias conclusiones y dice yo venía
regresando de república dominicana de un
viaje que hice solo en república
dominicana exactamente en tus venia de
república mexicana estaba bromeando con
la gente del avión con respecto a la dio
más español no decía palabras en español
jugaba jugando con la gente en el avión
cuando bajó del avión había los agentes
de aduanas los agentes de fronterizos de
canadá lo detuvieron y lo detuvieron
durante cinco horas y le hicieron pasar
exámenes médicos que es muy raro que le
hagan pasar lo hicieron español
por favor básica decía pero venía en el
avión estuvo diciendo alguna que otra
palabra probablemente los las personas
del avión los las aeromozas enviaron la
información a la gente del en tierra
él no sabe qué pasó pero lo cierto es
que lo detuvieron pensando que atrás
estaba transportando droga y quien dijo
que era mexicano
el mismo dice a mí me a mí me trataron
así porque parezco mexicano o porque soy
indígena y porque soy artista y también
la historia porque en realidad lo que él
dice él cuando dio sus razones fue a mí
me detuvieron porque parezco mexicano le
dijo de dónde vienen
bueno en todo caso lo que cierto es que
tuvo que pasar exámenes médicos durante
varios cuales el justificativo de pasar
exámenes médicos porque le dijeron que
pensaron que como era él lo dice en el
vídeo también que les presentamos que él
era lo que me hicieron pasar el examen
de radiografías
cómo se llama ecografía qué desastre le
dañan el paseo pues buscando que le
hayan dado los resultados pero una
persona así puedes denunciar también es
todo lo que está pasando y además como
no es el primer caso entonces están
reuniéndose las personas que han sido
entre comillas o no víctimas de algunos
actos un poco discriminatorios por parte
de las agentes
el perfil ajeno el fichaje nuestra
ocasión se refiere exactamente entonces
bueno me llamó la atención y bueno pues
mala suerte para él porque le dañaron el
regreso y del paseo y bueno pues ahora
que me hablen de méxico
a poco aquí tengo algunos saludos
[Música]
dice
ahora resultó que no sale en los top fun
en nuestro top fun es porque siempre se
conecta con nosotros en temas forestales
lugar hay actrices saludos al señor
andrés ramos la señora chapman paloma
leonardo y pablo y hoy viernes santo un
abrazo desde guadalajara saludos para ti
son unos saludos
y luis balderas y se oyendo desde san
ángel en chile y manuel escamilla desde
campeche méxico a poco
campeche y bueno yo les quería hablar
justamente estamos en semana santa
hoy es viernes santo viernes de pasión
me recordaba a andrés ahorita porque ya
digamos que mis conocimientos cristianos
ya un poco oxidados
conmigo y oxidados desde que decidí en
mi juventud alejarme de la iglesia
católica barranquillera bogotana y de
todo el país pero cuando yo era chico lo
que más me gustaba de la semana santa en
barranquilla es que se hace todo el
mundo en la en la ciudad hace dulces
preparan dulces caseros y dulces de todo
lo imaginable e inimaginable
de yuca de papa de lo que tú quieras de
coco de mango de frutas de tubérculos de
lo que sea así son unos dulces que son
de inicio si se sigue haciendo entonces
que son para menos años que usted es
solo un par de años haciendo agua en
realidad no sé si se sigue haciendo es y
esa tradición sigue de hecho no sé si
hay algún barranquillero por ahí en el
otro lado de la pantalla y del micrófono
que nos pueda decir desde barranquilla
con con qué pasó con esa tradición
barranquillera de hacer dulces bueno en
todo caso ese era el momento de ir a
visitar a familiares y amigos porque
bueno pues se reanudan los lazos y todo
eso era el domingo de pascuas y durante
todas las semanas las dos a la semana
durante todas
si preparaban unas ollas unas cosas que
durará toda la semana
entonces cuando uno llegaba de visita
esto se le daba enseguida a un dulce y
eso era que éste iban recibiendo con
dulce a todos los lugares donde fueras y
ese es exacto es ser algo delicioso que
cuando yo era niño me encantaba y bueno
pues cuando llegaba la semana santa no
armaba la casa y yo mismo la lista de
las personas porque son buenos pero no
hace los dulces más ricos o primero
decía ocho horas después pasamos al
altar el del acto y entonces se hace una
lista de los de los visitantes pero yo
tenga recuerdo en argentina de cuando de
la semana santa era
música sacra durante toda la semana en
la televisión eran los programas que
tenían que ver con cuestiones religiosas
yo queríamos venir tres veces en
distintos canales porque la pasaban a
repetición y veíamos diferentes tipos de
misiones que tienen que ver con la
semana santa o con cuestiones religiosas
pero no obviamente como no se comía
pescado
toda la semana no había ningún festival
como no había música rock
eso me acuerdo también era el domingo al
gran festejo como no se comía carne en
mi casa se hacía empanadas de humita
empanadas de pescado
y se hacía y mi papá que cocinaba la
famosísima paella valenciana entonces la
presencia el domingo una paella
valenciana
así que pero esa era digamos más
familiar que otra cosa pero tengo el
requisito también los huevos de pascua
el domingo eran infaltables
[Música]
pero me gustaría saber con andrés la
semana santa en bogotá ahorita vimos
algunas imágenes ya estamos viendo las
imágenes y comienza con bogotá
pero hay flagelación y todo toda la
procesión recreando todo pues cada una
de las estaciones de de cristo dentro de
la semana santa y en bogotá el plan es
ir a monserrate que es el cerro de en
los cerros orientales una iglesia muy
muy muy linda un lugar que es bellísimo
para recorrer y sobre todo en semana
santa
y para ir a la catedral la catedral de
sal de zipaquirá también es hermosa el
recorrido en tren también la misa dentro
de la catedral de sal que a propósito él
cada vez está más linda le ponen más
dulces le ponen más cosas que
la hace más atractiva pero si ese es el
plan y sobre todo en los pueblos
aledaños a bogotá donde las procesiones
como veía para que estábamos viendo de
que dramatiza todo cada una de las
estaciones de los sufrimientos
[Risas]
porque en indonesia en filipinas creo
que sí se crucifican se crucifican y se
fue te hace lástima hacer es increíble
pero mejor haber visto algunas en unas
caminatas que hice ahí por por españa
hay iglesias iglesias pequeñas grandes
por todos los caminos y yo entré me
acuerdo una vez a una iglesia y dije oh
mi dios yo a los niños no los traería
nunca aquí viste un cristo clavado
entras y la sangre
en ese caso
y especialmente los pueblos conservan
aún esas tradiciones ya andrés y tú
personalmente tu recuerdo de la semana
santa pues la semana santa ya bastante
tiempo también sabe un poco joven pero
pero
ha cambiado ha cambiado de una manera
muy rápida y yo recuerdo que cuando
estaba muy pequeño era a sentarse a ver
las películas de semana santa que
pasaban durante todo el día 2 ataban la
noche viendo viendo el diluvio incluso
siempre era bien bonito y el tema de la
cena y que comes pescado durante toda la
semana
comiendo en la semana santa y comiendo
pescado y realmente lo disfrutaba
horrores
yo comí arrocito solo es mucho más
saludos
no lo habíamos dicho de luís alfredo
marín desde canadá xantia sienten que
beckham dice luis alfredo marín dice el
dulce más famoso es el dulce de guandul
así cierto cuando les son lepe lepe así
pues es de tipo a
todos
de aquí en asturias luis alfredo como se
hacen los 250 gramos de panela dos
astillas de canela
[Música]
y media medio litro de leche de coco y 2
litros de agua
tienes que mandar esta receta pública
aprovechó la fecha qué bueno que tratan
el tema de las comidas de la temporada
etcétera
muchísimas gracias muy amable de tu
parte y bueno vamos a entonces ahora sí
a conversar con andrés sobre la razón de
ser de su visita aquí en canadá
bueno vamos por partes como decía el
descuartizador de londres
[Risas]
estás haciendo una pasantía aquí en este
momento aquí en montreal andino con
quién con qué organización están
haciendo y cómo sucedió eso cómo fue el
con taxi bueno la pasantía realmente se
da gracias a desarrollo y paz que a su
vez estar como comprometida mucho con
las causas sociales en américa latina y
como socia de aller que es la asociación
latinoamericana de educación radiofónica
pues llega la convocatoria a colombia a
una de las socias también que el grupo
comunicarte y allí aplicó como también
otros compañeros y comunicarte tu forma
parte de comunicación por parte en lugar
de nadie está el enlace así carlos rivas
es un organismo canal es un organismo
que nadie está basado en montreal así es
pertenece también a cáritas canadá y a
la iglesia
canadiense está así es y es gracias
digamos que a ellos ya su proyecto de
cuestas que es el el proyecto de
acompañamiento de quebec sin fronteras
es que podemos hacer la pasantía
con otros compañeros dos compañeras de
bolivia y una compañera de perú que
también su radio es radio cutivalú hace
parte también de aller y eso también
todo el proceso y justamente venimos a
hacer una pasantía en la vía de trabajar
un poco en los temas de derechos humanos
de américa latina' nutrir un poco ese
ese conocimiento que tenemos aquí en la
parte norte de américa y él y también
con todo lo que se ha venido haciendo en
sudamérica también el proyecto es
reciente o hace varios años que vienen
trayendo gente con este tipo de becas no
hay proyecto realmente no es reciente ya
lleva bastantes años
mayoritariamente hacen intercambios con
bolivia también con ecuador y bueno las
convocatorias se hacen prácticamente que
para nueve países de la de américa
latina en especial con diferentes
organizaciones podemos tal vez
escribirle a la gente que es la a leer
porque qué hace cuál es el trabajo que
hace esta asociación sí bueno a leer
realmente es una red de radios
comunitarias y hace mucho énfasis en la
democratización y en la alfabetización
de la comunicación entonces empieza con
una razón muy social hace ya bastante
tiempo y con con la unión de unas radios
comunitarias de católicas pero que con
su tiempo van tomando un tinte
progresista y van a empezar a
alfabetizar a los campesinos en temas
agrarios también en temas ya de
educación como lo es de matemáticas la
educación más formal a través de la
radio y a través de eso es que empiezan
a articular seña con a otras radios
de américa latina que tienen trabajos
sociales con campesinos indígenas
afrocolombianos y allí es como digamos
mi asociación grupo comunicarte él se
asocia también a leer para contribuir a
este trabajo todo bajo un algo muy
bonito que se llama el buen vivir el
sumak kawsay que es esa visión indígena
también de ver el mundo desde otra
perspectiva y cómo se inserta en esto
desarrollo y paz
bueno desarrollo y paz es inserta y se
asocia a leer justamente por el
compromiso de ver una alternativa a los
al desarrollo si de contribuir al cambio
social en muchas de las comunidades que
tienen diferentes conflictos
especialmente de conflictos de carácter
también ambiental como también con todo
el tema del extractivismo que está muy
fuerte y la parte también de muchos
líderes sociales en américa latina que
actualmente pues están en boca y que
realmente merece trasladar nuestra
visión a estas problemáticas
andrés y bueno comunicarte que es la
organización por hablar que tú trabaja y
que me gustaría
añadir digo como información que es como
dos palabras comunica al arte entonces
es que qué bien interesante como
concepto tú trabajas con esa
organización háblanos un poco de ella
bueno nosotros trabajamos y es una
organización
agrupa diferentes personas de varias
carreras de varias profesiones y que más
allá digamos de comprometerse también
con un poco la academia y la producción
investigativa se compromete mucho con
las comunidades en el tema de la
educación radiofónica entonces un poco
del trabajo que hacemos es ayudar a
muchos colegios con la radio escolar a
comunidades indígenas cabildos indígenas
que quieren tener su radio popular y
comunicar sus noticias porque bien
sabemos que precisamente en esa vía de
democratizar la comunicación es
importante que cada comunidad comunique
su sentir y no siempre estén supeditados
a esa visión de los grandes medios que a
veces pues reducida su mirada a lo que
el estado propone entonces justamente va
en esa vía y también sobre todo de
empoderar estas comunidades en sus
acciones entonces digamos que el tema de
capacitar ya en radio
unitaria y también sobre en audiovisual
porque también hacemos capacitaciones en
temas audiovisuales es que este sea el
medio sea la herramienta pero la
finalidad va más allá va más hacia el
empoderamiento de estas comunidades
hacia mostrar su desde su propio hablar
desde su propio sentido cuáles son esas
dificultades que ellos tienen cuáles son
las soluciones que afloran durante estos
procesos entonces hace y ya son
prácticamente estás terminando esta
pasantía son tres meses que hiciste en
estos tres meses estos tres meses pasear
pasear
menos frío claro pues sí disfrutar
muchísimo de montreal hemos conocido
también otras ciudades aledañas
nutrirnos de muchas ideas también y
sobre todo pues en temas de trabajo
hemos estado haciendo una pasantía con
el comité de desarrollo el comité por
los derechos humanos para américa latina
se dan
y allí hemos realizado un trabajo que
para mí ha sido muy gratificante porque
es una visión global de lo que es
américa latina y como también muchas
decisiones que tomamos acá en canadá por
ejemplo que la influencia americana
tenía a su vez américa latina en sus
acciones aquí entonces creo que ha sido
muy gratificante y el trabajo también ha
sido arduo eso me gusta porque venimos a
nutrirnos pero también a retroalimentar
todo el tiempo es es muy bello el
trabajo que se hace y la música es
importante también en comunicarte yo
estuve viendo en el sitio de ustedes un
vídeo en youtube que de jóvenes
no sé si el grupo se llama los dioses y
la canción soñadores social grupo de
soñadores
grupo bueno esto fue un trabajo que se
hace precisamente de justamente
si es un proyecto que se llama pásela en
paz y se hace en arauca como en un sitio
de arauquita con la con una emisora
comunitaria abra boquita exterior que
integra varios colegios y dos cabildos
indígenas y ellos lo que hacen es
empezar un proyecto en el que van a
contribuir al desarrollo de un proyecto
de vida para muchos de estos jóvenes que
habían estado inmersos en el conflicto
armado en zonas de narcotráfico porque
es una zona que está ha sido afectada
durante muchos años por la guerra
entonces parte de empezar un proyecto
sobre audiovisual sobre radio es que
ellos empezarán a tomar estas
herramientas y empezar a mostrar que su
territorio empezar a mostrar estas
convergencias entre el mestizo el
campesino el afro porque allí el
indígena porque allí viven todos juntos
y es mostrar como entre ellos se pueden
unir y hacer algo muy bueno como
no sé si podemos escuchar acá en el
estudio
la música
pero no sé si todos son fantásticos y el
contenido del mensaje que tiene me
parece decente con estos niños que están
cantando y reivindicando muy bonitas
y eso es un proyecto de formación de
capacitación audiovisual para jóvenes
indígenas en las regiones es fuera de la
ciudad de montreal es en quebec
particularmente pero han ido a américa
latina y han ido también a otras zonas
de canadá pero son principalmente con
las comunidades indígenas de acá y les
enseñan a producir cine a producir
videoclips a hacer un poco de montaje
audio también entonces es un proyecto
bien lindo también les gustaría conocer
encontraría gente que habla español en
wapping o nin sí sí justamente eso es lo
que queremos lograr con proyectos como
estos y es visibilizar a través de ellos
mismos de su propia voz estas
problemáticas y también como como ellos
las combaten que no llegan a unas
soluciones desde su propio hacer y creo
que eso es lo que se ha basado la
comunicación hacia un buen vivir
y ese sentir pensar de la comunicación
desde otra mirada estamos convirtiendo
muy interesante andrew podríamos pasar
todo el resto del tiempo que nos queda
pero estamos un poco limitado el tiempo
siempre pasa como agua entre los dedos
entonces muchísimas gracias por haber
por haberte desplazado para ver - aquí a
explicar ese proyecto tan tan chévere
por el que estás trabajando no
muchísimas gracias a ustedes y también
de verdad que bienvenidos también a
seguir pensando no sé pensando nos como
como un mundo que está tejido no en una
sola si está conectado y es muy bello
también animar un poco porque el trabajo
que se está haciendo grande en la
amazonía por la protección de la
amazonía y que nos compromete a todos
que eso es otra línea que también
trabajamos fuertemente nos concierne a
todos bueno muchísimas gracias puedes
pegarte con nosotros acá en el estudio
leonardo ahí
y un alien que nos está mirando pero
silencioso se llama héctor vilar
como vemos en un compañero ex compañero
de radio canal internacional cuando
radical en tercero amigo nuestro y que
te oliver dice un gran abrazo desde
montreal aplaudo esta forma de trabajo
por la intervención de la cooperación
internacional porque cree que es
importante la pregunta es por qué crees
que es importante la revaloración de la
cultura indígena no sólo en esta zona
sino en cualquier parte del mundo es una
pregunta que qué tienes hace bueno
realmente
hablar de revaloración de la cultura
indígena creo que lo cambiaría más por
una apropiación de la cultura indígena
porque hablar de revalorar es seguir
poniendo esa mirada europea europea
sobre las culturas indígenas que tienen
su propia forma de sentir su propia
forma de pensar cierto entonces creo que
lo que sí es realmente importante es el
reconocimiento a estas nuevas no estas
nuevas a estas diferentes formas de
pensar pero que contribuyen de alguna
manera a un cambio estructural en el
mundo
excelente leonardo la aplicación
recordémosle a las personas que nos
están escuchando que nosotros tenemos
una aplicación para que te la descargues
tú también andrés la aplicación la
aplicación de radio canadá internacional
es una aplicación en la aplicación que
puede usted bajarla de cualquiera de los
dos centros específicos uno para android
y otro para iphone play estoy para de
play store para android y en a pulsar
para para apple y en realidad es una
aplicación que usted instala en el
teléfono y puede ver todo el contenido
de radical internacional de una manera
muy sencilla de una manera mucho más
rápida que se estuviera navegando dentro
de la página de internet en el caso de
la aplicación en español tiene directo
en la entrada para la aplicación en
francés y en inglés y así sucesivamente
las otras aplicaciones pueden ir
conectándose si alguien que tenga la
facilidad en algunos de esos idiomas
también puede hacerlo se puede ver
nuestro programa ahora vengo entrenado
sé cómo abrirlo
e inmediatamente se va a ver
la sala allá arriba
y dicen nuestros programas en vídeo y lo
primero que sale en nuestro programa es
en vídeo es canadá las américas café que
está en vivo o sea acá es
lo de siempre mirar mirarme
[Música]
ahí estamos ahí ahí se ve ahí nos vemos
saludamos desde la aplicación es casi
como meterse adentro de meterse dentro
de terceros
así como la cinta fantástica entonces
pues es bastante super fast venir a
buscarla desde la página de internet de
radio qhana internacional tienen el gran
icono para ir directamente a la
promoción de la aplicación y de ahí uno
hace clic y va si el teléfono que se
reconoce el teléfono o sea uno va al
lugar para ya bajar la aplicación es
faltar a los invitados para bajar
nuestra plicas nos quedan siete minutos
7 minutos y tenemos cuatro temas que
presentan leonora chapman tú nos hablas
de una pequeña ciudad canadiense que
quiere recibir más inmigrantes si se
trata de la ciudad de coarí bien
y fíjense ustedes yo sabía y todos
nosotros sabemos que la ciudad de québec
es la más antigua ciudad de norteamérica
pues trier es la segunda ciudad más
antigua de norteamérica eso no lo sabía
haciendo el reportaje pues me di cuenta
de esto y es una ciudad que digamos que
además se donde esto está escrito
también lo encontré los costos de la
vivienda son los más baratos en todo
canadá el aval literario y en progreso
después y así y hablamos con sanz alonso
suazo director ejecutivo de saná eres
colombiano
significa servicio de acogida de nuevos
inmigrantes y conversamos justamente con
él porque dice que esté sana cumple está
cumpliendo 50 años y dice que a pesar de
que cualquier es una ciudad de 130 mil
habitantes recibe unos 250 inmigrantes
por año que son muy pocos que no
alcanzan que hay mucha necesidad de
gente
y entonces lo que conversamos entre
otras cosas y que se puede ver también
en el reportaje son las ventajas que él
dice de lo que es vivir en una ciudad
pequeña como mar y bien habla del tiempo
que se gana viviendo en una ciudad
pequeña habla del costo de la vida en
relación a otras viviendas me imagino
que de esa manera parando claro y con
todo pero además todo es más barato
comparando con toronto o vancouver
montreal las grandes ciudades habla de
estudios universitarios hay que recordar
que allí está la universidad de quebec
en el ínter y tiene dos más de dos mil
estudiantes universitarios extranjeros
que vienen de 50 países tiene una oferta
laboral muy grande con él y lo que él
dice se hace falta a gente especializada
y gente no especializada es un sector
que está muy en desarrollo del sector
industrial habla de empresarios que
están creando sus latinoamericanos que
están creando sus propias empresas
pequeñas que llegan con un conocimiento
por ejemplo de panadería o de delfín de
lo que se les ocurre y ponen negocios
entonces es una ciudad
y muy pujante que está creciendo y que
necesita un poco de eso además se unen
tres ríos ahí por eso llama trois
riviéres entonces
y para los que buscan una vida tranquila
con hijos pequeños eso realmente es lo
ideal
bueno ya sabes madre si quieres emigrar
a canadá
[Risas]
bueno y tu paloma y tu me dice que nos
dice es más bien que el niño gracias a
leonora y tú nos dices que niños y
jóvenes salen perdiendo en con la
reforma educativa de la provincia de
ontario porque porque resulta que
hablamos ya quienes en el programa en
alguna ocasión de los cortes que fueron
anunciados por parte del gobierno de
docs ford en ontario y que van a afectar
particularmente al sector educativo en
esa provincia entonces tuve la
oportunidad de conversar con cristina
guerrero que ella es pedagoga y trabaja
con el consejo escolar público de
toronto y ella me explica los cortes son
tan importantes
y tan dañinos para todo el sistema que
los más afectados serán justamente los
niños y los jóvenes que están yendo a la
escuela y que van a perder servicios van
a estar pensando ampliar los grupos 2
cada maestro tendrá más niños en sus
clases se van a cortar los los servicios
de pe de pedagogía de consejos pedal de
consejeros pedagógicos dentro de cada
una de las de los consejos escolares de
la provincia entonces les preocupa mucho
y dice los que salen perdiendo son
siempre los niños y los jóvenes y no es
posible que no digamos nada entonces muy
interesante conversar con cristina
guerrero que es además una dop tiene un
doctorado en pedagogía y particularmente
se especializó en jóvenes latinos y su
nivel de de abandono escolar entonces
muy interesante estado que está la chica
bueno todos estos reportajes y
entrevistas los pueden escuchar en
nuestro sitio internet
rcn punto sea antes de que se me olvide
hoy en los controles técnicos máxima la
abrí marca andrés de zhang y pierre útil
y seguimos acá
encadenamos con leonardo sin menos que
tú nos habla de leonardo de un acuerdo
entre dos gigantes amazon y google sigue
en realidad el título dice así como que
el armisticio
alguien me dijo armisticio no es una
guerra justamente entre ellos entre esta
gente que bueno tiene el monopolio en
distintos sectores de la tecnología en
este caso google y youtube
acaban de hacer flexibilizar un poquito
porque su causación exacto porque las
plataformas
por ejemplo las plataformas que tienen
que ver con amazon que tiene un pequeño
conector que va al televisor que uno
puede ver programas de amazon no podía
ver youtube porque era de la empresa
opuesta y pasaba alrededor de otro caso
lo que hicieron fue flexibilizar un poco
y dentro de un par de meses uno va a
poder ver programación de amazon en
cosas que tienen
en el dispositivo google y viceversa así
que es muy bien que se resuelva eso yo
por mi parte los invito a escuchar un
reportaje que hice sobre una exposición
que terminó ayer justamente pero que se
va a trasladar a otros lugares de la
ciudad es una exposición sobre una
exposición realidad le dicen ellos sobre
los
los taxis de la utilización de los
teléfonos celulares textos mientras se
conduce para sensibilizar a la gente del
peligro de textear mientras se está
manejando estamos allí entonces pues
agarraron tres automóviles que
y copiaron muy bien lo replicaron muy
bien de tres accidentes en los que
terminaron muertos y personas muy
heridas entonces en ese en esa
exposición te sensibiliza a que no
utilices el teléfono celular mientras se
está conduciendo y eso fue todo por este
programa de canadá en las américas de
este fin de semana jueves viernes 19 en
sábado
saludos y saludos andrés ramos desde
colombia
bueno eso fue todo para este programa
vuelvan nuevamente el viernes próximo
que aquí vamos a estar todos porque ha
estado felicidades y feliz semana santa
[Música]